Bunsen burner is perhaps one of the most
iconic symbols of chemistry a Bunsen
burner just to remind you consists of a
small jet down here with two holes and a
metal cylinder that you can rotate so
that you can open and shut those holes
and the gas comes down the tube up the
jet and air comes through these big
holes and the flame comes out at the top
if you look at the flame you can see
different parts are different colors but
most people just have to take their
teacher or professor's word that some
bits of the flame are hotter than others
with a thermal-imaging camera we can
actually show you that this is true
and also you can see more structure to
the flame than you can with your eye so
Bunsen burners are usually used in two
different modes there's the mode where
the air holes are covered up and you get
quite a large yellow wavy flame the
yellow color is from hot carbon
particles which are radiating out heat
in the cooler mode when you haven't got
much air the gas comes up and catches
fire when it comes in contact with air
the heat of the flame generates carbon
particles from incomplete combustion of
the methane which is in the gas and
eventually those particles burn but the
yellow color of the flame comes from
those carbon particles when the holes
are closed the gas doesn't meet any air
until it gets to the top when we open
the holes we mix gas and air down here
and then they burn right at the top and
they burst into flames and the flame is
much hotter because the reaction is much
faster now the thing that intrigues me
is that I've always been taught that the
blue colored cone that you see on the
Bunsen burner ends at its tip at the
hottest place in the flame the truth is
slightly more complicated and what I was
told there's all sorts of turbulence
inside the flame and the hottest point
moves around a bit but I think why we
were told keep whatever your heating
particularly if you're trying to do
glassblowing if you keep the glass at
the tip of the blue cone you will be on
average at the hottest point in the
flame it doesn't mean that any instant
that is the hottest part and for me it
is really very beautiful
watching these flames and to see how the
temperature varies is really very nice
and what you can't see with your naked
eye but you can see really nicely with
the camera is the cool layer of air it's
not cold but it's still quite hot but
much
that is round the edge of the flame the
other thing is that it's nice to see how
the heat moves down the bouncing burner
of course most chemists know or they
learn by experience that when you switch
a Bunsen burner off the top is hot if
you look at the way the bouncing burner
is constructed you can see that there's
actually a double layer of metal
I suspect the idea of that is to stop
you burning your fingers quite so badly
but it still gets pretty hot it must be
said and we explained this on our Bunsen
burner video that the burner was
probably invented by Bunsen's technician
not by Benson professors in those days
tended to take credit for their
technicians work but Bunsen himself
apparently used to burn his fingers so
badly that the skin was black and
smoking when he was trying to do
glassblowing nowadays glass blowers have
much more elegant torches as you will
have seen on some of our videos of
glassblowing Neal our technician had an
interesting idea of taking a rod of
carbon and he put it into the flame
he had a carbon rod because glass
blowers often use carbon rods to touch
on their glass because the glass even
when it's molten does not stick to the
carbon and if you watch you can see how
the heat gradually goes along the rod
and the rod gets hotter and hotter
anneal is quite a tough guide but
eventually it got even too hot for him
to hold and he had to put it down in the
hurry
but it is a very nice demonstration of
how heat can be conducted along rods
like that
we'd like to thank Google's making in
science team for making this video
possible it's not the only film they've
supported lately there's a bunch of
stuff across lots of channels I'll put a
link on the screen and in the video
description and while you're exploring
other parts of YouTube why not check out
my channel objectivity where every week
we look at a new science treasure from
archives at the Royal Society we've just
posted our 100th object and it's a real
special one I'll also put links on the
screen and in the video description